this opening day in april in detroit is
a reminder that warmer days are on the
horizon
we'll remember the first game of this
season for a while
it feels like home again
welcome back to opening day on the
mountain for detroit his second
consecutive opening day not is matthew
boyd it's a pretty simple task today
throw strikes avoid that big contact and
keep the guys in the dugout as much as
possible
1-2
rolled it over to second
beautiful good inning from matthew boyd
nice start
11 pitches and he's through the first
shane bieber for the bottom half of the
first inning and a great season 8-1 on
163 era he did face the tigers twice
last year he was 2-0 with a 184 and he's
five and one in his career
swinging a mess he threw the fastball by
him upstairs and that is out number two
and willy castro is shane bieber's first
strikeout victim in 2021 it's up to
miguel starting to get hot at the end of
spring training
1-1 sky to right
deep and gone
miguel cabreras
350th as a tiger
second baseman
he's sleeping he thought it was a double
how about that
on opening
oh my gosh the outfielder couldn't
mickey couldn't see he slid into second
we've got a white out
[Applause]
who says he doesn't like the cold
yep it's out
looks like it hit the pipe above that
line
keep the ball it's important
it's a big one
swinging a mess he got him with a
breaking ball so bieber strikes out two
but the tigers get two on the board
just go ahead and stay right there with
the breaking ball he's got a great feel
for that three straight that was just
off the plate you can't take anything
you got to make sure you may lose a
little bit on that fastball if you
continue to throw the cutter he's got
the good curve well he's starting to
find it that's nine straight strikes but
it got away
and victor reyes is going to be safe on
the wild pitch now here's jacoby jones
hammered to left
on a line drive up against the wall
reyes will chug for third chip hale is
going to wave him home
reyes legging it out and he beats the
throw
would you just say chef are you going to
pressure him on the bases
that's how it's when it works right chip
hale forced the issue right there and
waving in uh reyes
the 2-2 and a swing and a miss bieber
with a much-needed strikeout his third
of the inning but there are only two
down
because of that wild pitch earlier
foul tipped into the glove of ramos for
out number two
second strikeout for matthew it looked
like he took a little off there
a breaking ball that he located well
kind of a backdoor slider starts off the
plate away and then catches the outside
corner
there's a call july right that's six
strikeouts for shane bieber
there it is breaking ball and he strikes
him out there it is
sprinkles seven strikeouts for shane
bieber
oh two to naylor
and right side nice play by carrera gets
the man at second for the second out
great play great range on the part of
miguel cabrera he's done it with a homer
and he stole away an rbi single from
josh naylor there
well yeah you look at bieber in his
career and this is start number 65
for him in his career got him and i
think the other four starters on this
indians ball club have about 70 starts
nine k's for shane bieber strikes out
two here in the fourth
off the end of the bat it should work
jacoby jones lets victor reyes take care
of it and matthew boyd navigates a tough
inning there in the fifth and keeps
cleveland off the board
got him to chase the high fastball and
that is ten strikeouts for bieber this
is elevated but it has movement he
didn't swing at the one it was a little
too far in the pitch before this but
he's got to see this one and then check
the movement and boy that's about chin
high so he ends up getting him on the
fastball
double digit strikeouts out number two
in the fifth how about that already tied
for eighth most in club history with c
c sabathia
there you go
perfectly
located fastball that's 11 strikeouts
for shane bieber
swinging a miss he went fishing at 12.
and had no chance
12 k's for bieber as he has fanned the
first two in the sixth inning
jose cisnero starts the seventh he got
the final out in the sixth
nice pitch
perez to start the seventh
back-to-back strikeouts here in the
seventh for jose cisnero
aj hinch sprints to the mound and says
come on daniel norris
you need to get the final out here in
the seventh
strike him out
cisnero then norris they combine to
strike out the cleveland side in the
seventh catcher roberto perez
will
come to the plate now
oh there's a ball drilled deep left
field grossman's back he's out of room
it's out of here it's a one-run game
roberto perez with his first home run
in game number one and it comes in the
clutch here in the ninth to close the
gap to a single digit
right here
the 1-2
popped it up shadow right scope is out
and he's got it
and the tigers celebrate an opening day
victory 3-2
over the indians